>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
A THOUGHT EXPERIMENT.
IF YOU WANTED TO TURN A FREE
COUNTRY INTO A DICTATORSHIP, HOW
WOULD YOU DO IT?
WHAT IS THE FIRST FREEDOM YOU
WOULD CURTAIL?
THE FOUNDERS OF THE COUNTRY
THOUGHT ABOUT THAT QUESTION.
THEY CONCLUDED THAT IT WASN'T
EVEN CLOSE.
THE FREEDOM THAT MATTERS IS THE
FREEDOM OF SPEECH.
THAT'S THE MOST BASIC OF ALL OF
THE FREEDOMS.
THAT'S WHY IT'S ENSHRINED IN THE
FIRST AMENDMENT TO THE BILL OF
RIGHTS.
IT'S CENTRAL NOT ONLY TO FREEDOM
BUT TO HUMANITY.
WE CAN SPEAK.
THAT'S OUR POWER.
IN THE BEGINNING WAS THE WORD
DECLARES JOHN IN THE OPENING OF
THE FOURTH GOSPEL.
THE WORD IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING WE HAVE.
TAKE AWAY OUR ABILITY TO CHOOSE
OUR OWN WORDS AND WE ARE NO
LONGER HUMAN.
WE ARE SUBJECT AND CHATTEL.
AUTHORITIARIANS UNDERSTAND THIS.
THEY MATE FREEDOM OF SPEECH.
THEY WOULD LET YOU HAVE
A MACHINE GONE BEFORE THEY ALLOW
YOU TO SAY WHAT YOU WANT.
WITH A GUN YOU CAN KILL
PEOPLE -- BUT WITH WORDS YOU CAN
EXPOSE THEM.
WITH WORDS YOU CAN CHANGE THE
WORLD.
THERE HAS NEVER BEEN A DEEP
CHANGE THAT NOT BEGIN WITH
WORDS.
NOT WITH VIOLENCE BUT WITH
THAT'S WHY THEY ARE SO FOCUSSED
ON WHAT YOU CAN SAY.
ON THE WORDS YOU CAN USE.
THEY UNDERSTAND THE POWER OF
WORDS.
ELON MUSK UNDERSTANDS THIS TOO.
THAT'S WHY HE IS TRYING TO BUY
TWITTER.
NOT BECAUSE HE NEEDS ANOTHER
COMPANY.
ELON MUSK PURCHASING TWITTER IS
MORE THAN A CHANGE TO THE MEDIA
LANDSCAPE.
IT IS A TRUE THREAT TO THE
PEOPLE IN CHARGE.
ALLOWING FREEDOM OF SPEECH
ALLOWS THE POSSIBILITY OF
A REVOLUTION FROM BELOW AGAINST
THE FORCES DESTROYING THIS
COUNTRY AND THE WEST.
EVERYTHING RIDES ON THIS.
THEY KNOW IT.
YOU MAY NOT BUT THEY DO.
THEY HAVE TO DO EVERYTHING THEY
CAN TO DESTROY MUSK WHO WAS JUST
THE OTHER DAY A HERO TO HIM.
HE IS THE ELECTRIC CAR GUY.
THEY DON'T EVEN MENTION HIS
ELECTRIC CARS ANYMORE.
HE IS DOING THE ONE THING YOU
ARE NOT ALLOWED TO DO:
GIVING VOICE TO PEOPLE.
THEY CALLED HIM A RACIST.
HE IS FROM SOUTH AFRICA.
HE WAS TOO RICH TO CARE THEY
MOVED ON.
SOME ARGUED THAT ELON MUSK WAS
UNDER-PAYING FOR TWITTER.
IT'S OBVIOUS HE IS OVER-PAYING.
THEN THE "WASHINGTON POST" MAX
GOT IN.
THERE WAS ANOTHER WAR HE COULD
SUPPORT.
TO SAVE DEMOCRACY MAX BOOT
INFORMED US WE NEED MORE CONTENT
MODERATION ON TWITTER.
NO FREE SPEECH ALLOWED.
WHO DOES CENSORSHIP HELP?
THE POWERFUL.
WHO DOES IT HURT?
THE WEAK.
WORDS ARE ALL THEY HAVE.
TAKE THEIR ABILITY TO SAY WHAT
THEY THINK AWAY FROM THEM AND
THEY HAVE NO POWER AT ALL.
TONIGHT AFTER 6 MONTHS OF
WATCHING THIS DRAMA, IT LOOKS
LIKE THEY FAILED TO STOP ELON
MUSK FROM BUYING TWITTER.
RIGHT NOW THE DEAL WILL GO
THROUGH.
TWITTER LOCKED EMPLOYEES STOCKS
SO SOME TRANSACTION IS IMMINENT.
A SOURCE TOLD THIS SHOW THAT
WITHIN 2 WEEKS MUSK WILL OWN
TWITTER.
HE SAID HE IS DOING THIS IN
ORDER TO GIVE VOICE TO PEOPLE
WHO HAVE NO VOICE.
TWITTER BANNED THE SITTING
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
FROM SPEAKING.
MAKING IT CLEAR WHO HAS THE REAL
POWER.
NOT THE U.S. GOVERNMENT.
CORPORATIONS LIKE TWITTER WHICH
CONTROL SPEECH.
THEY DID EVERYTHING THEY COULD
TO STOP THIS FROM HAPPENING BUT
FAILED.
NOW THEY ARE ATTEMPTING TO
DESTROY MUSK THE MAN.
WE ARE NOT CARRYING WATER FOR
MUSK.
HE MAY HAVE WEIRD AGENDAS BUT
IT'S ONLY ABOUT SPEECH.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS
INVESTIGATING MUSK FOR REASONS
NO ONE CAN EXPLAIN.
DAVID GOT INVOLVED BECAUSE THERE
IS NO LEVEL TO WHICH HE WILL NOT
STOOP IN DEFENSE OF PEOPLE IN
CHARGE.
HE IS CALLING FOR THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION TO SEIZE MUSK'S
SATELLITES.
THE ONES HE HAS GIVEN FOR FREE
TO THE GOVERNMENT OF UKRAINE TO
USE IN THE WAR EFFORT AGAINST
RUSSIA.
QUOTE:
THE U.S. SHOULD NATIONALIZE STAR
LINK THE SATELLITE COMPANY FAST.
IF YOU DON'T LIKE HIS POLITICS
SEIZE HIS STUFF.
ALL THAT MATTERS IS THE CALL FOR
ORDINARY AMERICANS TO SAY WHAT
THEY REALLY THINK.
JUST TAKE HIS STUFF BY FORCE.
CNN IS CALLING MUSK AN AGENT OF
RUSSIA BECAUSE HE WILL PROVIDE
SATELLITES TO UKRAINE FREE OF
CHARGE.
>> LAST WEEK REPORTS EMERGED OF
SUDDEN STAR LINK OUTAGES ON THE
FRONT LINE AS TROOPS FOUGHT TO
TAKE BACK TERRITORY.
>> THEY ARE PUZZLED WHY THAT IS
GOING ON.
SOMETHING SPACE-X IS DOING OR
COMING FROM ELON?
>> IT IS NEWS OF THE FUNDING
REQUEST TO THE PENTAGON COME AS
MUSK'S SUPPORT OF UKRAINE IS
QUESTIONED AFTER HE PROPOSED
A PEACE DEAL SUGGESTING THAT
UKRAINE RELINQUISH CRIMEA TO
RUSSIA.
>> THAT PEACE PLAN WAS SEEN IN
UKRAINE AS BEING PRO-RUSSIAN,
ONE UKRAINIAN DIPLOMAT TOLD MUSK
TO F-OFF.
>> Tucker: OKAY.
DO YOU THINK THEY CARE ABOUT
RUSSIA AND UKRAINE?
OF COURSE NOT.
IF THEY DID THEY WOULD TRY TO
PUSH A PEACE DEAL.
IT'S ABOUT THE UNITED STATES AND
MUSK COMMITTING THE UNFORGIVABLE
SIN TO ALLOW YOU TO SAY WHAT YOU
THINK ABOUT THE PEOPLE IN
CHARGE.
IT GIVES YOU A LITTLE POWER.
THEY ARE TERRIFIED HE WILL
SUCCEED.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING IS THE
DESPERATION OF A CLASS OF PEOPLE
RUNNING THE COUNTRY WHO FEEL
LIKE THEY ARE LOSING POWER.
THEY ARE PANICKED.
YOU CAN FEEL IT.
THE LIFESTYLE LIBERALS WHO
WORKED TO CRUSH THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, WHO HAVE BEEN YELLING AT
YOU ON TELEVISION FOR 5 YEARS,
FEEL LIKE IT'S ALL SLIPPING
AWAY.
WE ARE IN DEEP TROUBLE.
READY THE HELICOPTERS WE HAVE TO
GET OUT OF HERE.
IT'S INTERESTING.
UNLIKE PREVIOUS REGIMES THESE
ARE NOT PEOPLE IN UNIFORM.
THESE ARE CHIRPING MIDDLE AGED
WOMEN.
WE SHOWED THIS WOMAN SAYING WE
NEED A LOT MORE CENSORSHIP IN
THIS COUNTRY.
YOU CAN'T GO TO THE BATHROOM.
SHUT UP AND OBEY.
THIS IS THE FACE OF SOUL
CRUSHIN
CRUSHING FASCIST LIBERALISM.
PEOPLE LIKE BRANDI ARE ITS STORM
TROOPER.
SHE WROTE A GUY TO FIND WHERE
PEOPLE LIVE IF THEY ARE GUILTY
OF WRONG THINK.
SHE SITS BACK AND WATCHES WHAT
HAPPENS.
THEIR LIVES ARE DESTROYED.
FOR THAT SERVICE TO THE PEOPLE
IN CHARGE, CORPORATE MEDIA
CELEBRATES HERE AS A HERO.
THEY HAVE HER ON TO CALL FOR
EVEN MORE CENSORSHIP.
>> WE ARE AT THE TAIL END OF THE
RALLY.
YOU HEAR THIS IS AN ANTI-MANDATE
THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE TOLD US.
ALL OF THE SPEAKERS WE HAVE SEEN
TODAY HAVE BEEN -- IT'S BEEN
A MISINFORMATION FEST.
WE HAVE SEEN MISINFORMATION
ABOUT THE DANGERS OF VACCINES.
THIS IS AN EXTREME MESSAGE.
WE MAY NOT SEE HARM LIKE JANUARY
6TH BUT HEALTH EXPERTS SAY THIS
CAUSES HARM JUST THE SAME.
MANDATES WORK TO GET PEOPLE TO
SAY I DON'T WANT TO LOSE MY JOB
OR I WANT TO FLY ON THE PLANE.
WHATEVER THE MANDATE IS RULING.
THAT IS GOOD NEWS.
WE HAVE THE FIRST AMENDMENT AND
SPECIFIC THINGS IN OUR COUNTRY
THAT MAKE IT A MORE DIFFICULT TO
TEACH ON THE INTERNET.
IT'S A VERY HARD PROBLEM.
>> Tucker: THERE ARE PEOPLE OUT
THERE WHO DON'T WANT TO LOSE
THEIR JOBS.
THEY WANT TO FLY ON AIRPLANES
BUT THEY CAN'T FOR THEIR OWN
GOOD.
SHUT UP AND STOP TALKING.
THE PROBLEM PER PEOPLE LIKE
BRANDI AND THE HUNDREDS OF
PEOPLE JUST LIKE HER IN
CORPORATE MEDIA WHO WAKE UP
EVERY MORNING, NO ONE BELIEVES
THEM ANYMORE.
PEOPLE DON'T CARE IF THEY ARE
CALLED NAMES.
YOU ARE TRAFFICKING
MISINFORMATION AND YOU ARE A
RACIST.
I DON'T CARE WHAT YOU SAY.
YOU ARE TOTALLY DISCREDITED.
YOU ARE A JOKE!
THAT SUGGESTS THERE IS A CHANGE
COMING.
WE MAY HAVE A COUNTRY SOON WHERE
PEOPLE CAN SAY WHAT THEY THINK.
WHEN THEY DO.
THEY CAN LIVE WITH DIGNITY AGAIN
LIKE FREE PEOPLE.
PEOPLE ARE RUNNING FOR OFFICE
WHO WILL NOT BE CONTROLLED BY
UNFAIR ATTACKS FROM THEIR
OPPONENTS.
THEY UNSHACKLED THEMSELVES.
J.D. VANCE IS ONE OF THEM
RUNNING AGAINST TIM REINER.
RYAN.
RYAN IS WORRIED HE WILL LOSE.
RYAN SAID I HAVE TO STOP J.D.
VANCE -- I DON'T WANT TO ARGUE
WITH HIM.
SO I WILL CALL HIM A RACIST.
THAT WILL STOP HIM.
WATCH HOW J.D. VANCE RESPONDED
LAST NIGHT IN THE DEBATE.
>> THIS GREAT DEPLACEMENT THEORY
WAS THE MOTIVATOR FOR THE
SHOOTER IN BUFFALO.
-- REPLACEMENT.
SOME SICKO GOT THIS INFORMATION
HE IS PEDDLING WITH THE
EXTREMISTS.
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREEN AND TED
CRUZ.
THEY WANTED TO STOKE RACIAL
VIOLENCE.
>> THIS IS DISGUSTING.
WHAT HAPPENS IS MY OWN CHILDREN,
MY BI-RACIAL CHILDREN ARE
ATTACKED BY SCUM BAGS ONLINE AND
IN PERSON BECAUSE YOU ARE SO
DESPERATE FOR POLITICAL POWER
YOU WILL ACCUSE ME OF FATHER OF
THREE BEAUTIFUL BIRACIAL BABIES
THEY ARE RACISTS.
YOU CAN BELIEVE IN THE COUNTRY
WITHOUT BEING A RACIST.
THIS SHOWS HOW DESPERATE HE IS
FOR POLITICAL POWER.
>> Tucker: WE ARE SICK OF IT.
NOT JUST J.D. VANCE IS SICK OF
IT.
BUT EVERY NORMAL PERSON WHO
LIVES HERE OF ALL COLORS AND A